inglaterra se configura durante un mes
bares restaurantes y actividades no
esenciales cerrarán desde el próximo
jueves hasta el 2 de diciembre escocia
gales e irlanda del norte tendrán
autonomía sobre los cierres
ahora es momento de tomar medidas porque
no hay alternativa desde el jueves hasta
principios de diciembre debemos
quedarnos en casa
sólo se podrá salir por cuestiones
específicas incluyendo educación trabajo
si es que no se puede hacer desde casa
para hacer ejercicio y recreación al
aire libre
por razones médicas y para escapar de
lesiones o daños
intuit
para comprar alimentos y artículos
básicos y para brindar atención a
personas vulnerables como voluntarios de
bolonia algo que se replica en casi toda
europa austria también impuso un
confinamiento de un mes y cierre de
establecimientos no esenciales algo que
ya provocó protestas frente a la sede
gubernamental
grecia tendrá un cierre parcial donde
solo se verán afectados hoteles
restaurantes y la industria de la
cultura pero el comercio seguirá
operando en portugal por su parte se
anunció que el 70% de la población
estará confinada desde el 4 de noviembre
y en italia ante la posibilidad de
restricciones más duras cientos de
personas salieron a la calle a pedir
ayuda económica ver qué habitante que
está claro que la crisis que seguirá y
que ha dañado la economía la pagará la
población y estamos aquí para hacer que
los patrones paguen la crisis en el amor
falta caer a la crisis de patrones el
primer confinamiento ya golpeó con
dureza a la mayoría de países europeos
que vieron caídas históricas en su pib
ahora miles de personas temen que otro
encierro sea el golpe definitivo a sus
negocios y puestos de trabajo